on en vient à la guerre en ukraine
bientôt six mois qu'elle a débuté dans
le sud du pays à gijon les forces
ukrainienne envisage depuis plusieurs
jours une contre-offensive une ville
tombait pearson rapidement et sans
combat aux mains des russes les
précisions de mélina huet notre envoyé
spécial dans le pays
elle pilonne depuis plusieurs semaines
systématiquement deux ponts
essentiellement le pont d'antonov cas et
le pont de novak caroff cas qui sont des
ponts stratégique parce que de la même
manière qu'on crée mais en fait ils
permettent le réapprovisionnement en
munitions et en matériel lourd
aujourd'hui ils sont inexploitables
peut-être même à pied un nous dit
certains officiels ukrainien donc
impossible pour les russes de se
réapprovisionner il se trouve qu'il ya
deux jours il ya même des postes de
commandement russe qui ont décidé de se
replier à l'est de dniepr de cette de ce
fleuve qui est très très difficile
d'accès que l'on ne peut pas traverser à
pied donc ces ponts sont nécessaires sa
montre à tout le moins une angoisse un
de l'armée russe qui commence à paniquer
qu'ils pensent être encerclée si jamais
il y à une contre-offensive vers red sun
ray lawson on rappelle que c'est l'une
des procès la première ville qui a été
prise par les russes et sans grand
combat mais les ukrainiens veulent
absolument la récupérer il ya deux
difficultés pour les ukrainiens la
première c'est que pour le moment ils
pilonnent des des ponts et ils ont le
matériel nécessaire en a retiré pour le
faire mais s'ils veulent reprendre elson
il s'agira d'une bataille d'enfants très
et là il faudrait beaucoup d'hommes et
on ne sait absolument pas à ce stade
puisque l'armée ukrainienne communique
très peu s'ils ont les ressources
nécessaires en sommes pour pouvoir
reprendre une ville comme car comme
repsol et la deuxième chose c'est que et
bien l'automne approche et que les
conditions vont de plus en plus être
difficile donc cette contre-offensive
contre offensive s'il elle doit être
mené doit se faire avant le mois de
novembre voir le mois d'octobre et
j'ajoute que le secrétaire général de
l'onu antonio guterres s va se rendre ce
jeudi en ukraine